well ahead of match the excitement  proved just  too much as some fans attempted to get  into wembley without tickets  a spokesperson for wembley stadium said  then they were dealing with an  incident that occurred at the outer  security perimeter area of the stadium  with support from the police they say  that safety measures were activated  and there were no security breaches of  people without tickets  getting inside the stadium but if you  can see what's happening  now behind me this is the main stairs  leading up to wembley this is at the end  of wembley way  and fans have broken through there  shouldn't be anybody  on those stairs at all